- Hello there. I’m Nick Saban, and this week, we’re going to say
goodbye…
to an Urban legend.
- Mr. Meyer, 'tis Christmas, and I wondered if I could get more carries?
- And you are?
- James Robinson, sir. I was a pretty big deal in fantasy—
- All right, dips--ts, line up for your physical abuse.
- Yes, sir!
- This is just football culture, I guess.
- Look, everyone! I lit it up again.
- I see you. Someone finally sees you.
- Bah humbug.
Pizza, you’re the only one I trust.
- Prayers up! It’s Tim Tebow, the Ghost of Urban Past.
We begin at Florid—
- OH, GOSH. I FEEL LIKE MY EYES HAVE SINNED.
- HO, HO! IT IS I, CHIP KELLY, THE GHOST OF URBAN PRESENT!
Bobby Petrino had a thing.
- Wait, who am I?
“If you play well, I’ll give you a little sticker for your helmet.”
- [Laughing]
- See, the college ways don’t work in the pros…Urban?
- [Urban Meyer:] It would be rude for me not to take a photo.
- You see? Tiny Trevor—
- may not make it because of one bad coach.
- Next!
Ghost of Urban Future, show me how great I am.
- Hello, welcome to the Big Ten Network. Let’s talk about Rutgers for 12 hours.
- I see now. Someone will always hire me!
You, boy! What jobs are open?
- Why, yours, sir!
- Huzzah! A kicked goose for everyone!
- ...And everyone realized coaches should stay
in college, where they are kings.
Merry Christmas, y'all.